when you call Italian something
they'll [__] tell you three things
that they are but then they'll disagree
with you about the one thing that you
called them it is the most Italian thing
you can [__] do well you [__] lied
Vinnie you technically Allied I tell you
what I may be a disgusting piece of [__]
I may be 45 pounds over [__] way
and I may also have taken some flying
lessons but one thing I'm not is a
goddamn Maya
Vinnie Vinnie you're very emotional I
may work part-time at SeaWorld okay
I may have hair that of a lesbian woke
liberal
okay
and they may not be able to moonwalk for
[__]
but one thing I'm not
is emotional do you understand me the
whole thing about the times is you shift
the emotion you scream and then you
soften it up you know